good morning Millennials welcome back to
the chosen happy Tuesday that feels like
a Monday that feels like also like a
Thursday how is everyone doing it is
blizzarding here in New York it's just
like so not the vibe you know like the
from Mexico like [__] off I like oh
we're on totally different wavelengths
cuz we're expecting a cold front this
week and it's just not coming fast
enough for your girl well that I
understand cuz like you decided to live
in Florida for some reason and it's like
so hot and miserable so of course you
would be looking forward to
so if you're not looking for Mexican
climate Floridian climate nor New York
climate right now what are you looking
for turd no no it's a good question it's
a good question I am looking for 65 in
sunny I am always looking for 65 and
sunny yeah I think like San Diego is
always 65 and sunny not Ben offer being
in San Diego right now of course classic
Ben you want to hear the craziest thing
I mean you know it already cuz I told
you but Ben and I were Mexico together
and we flew home separately I flew home
to New York he flew home he flew to San
Diego and we both have the same suitcase
it's a black away carry-on and when we
got out of the car we were like by the
way make sure we have each other's
correct bags before we get on the plane
because we're going on separate planes
and my plane is literally taking off and
Ben calls me and he's like I have your
bag I thought you checked what did the
check in tail that could be wrong we
didn't check oh but you said make sure
you have your right bag yeah we were
like later before we like you know
officially part ways let's make sure
yeah we didn't for me like I don't
really care because I'm going home I
have everything I need at home you know
Ben is going on a weekl long work trip
speaking at a conference this morning
with literally suitcase full of bathing
suits and coverups and like sparkly
dresses well he could sell your wares
and buy some things for himself so he
hit up a Nordstrom Rack last night
beautiful he said he got some great
things I'm sure he did I'm sure he loved
the opportunity to do a last minute shop
but like when I tell you Bennis doesn't
panic really ever he's and I was
honestly like you're being a little
dramatic like you're not going to a
third world country like you're going to
California go to a mall right you're a
boy you're not going to a Gala like
you're being at a conference buy a
button down and some jeans like please I
and he was really being like ask the
flight attendant if they could turn I'm
like are you [__] kiding ask the
flight attendant if they could turn he
was being like so nuts and I was like
listen I know it's not ideal but like
you need to get a grip now if it had
been me totally different like makeup
Glam like so different for girls for a
boy I really want it to be like grow up
yeah still you're headed towards
civilization you can replace some things
but it's not about like will I be able
to access a dress it's
like it's the dress no he's like
podcasting like what do you wear on a
podcast like literally a t-shirt please
please if you were going to La for like
a week of podcasting and you lost your
things it would be extremely
inconvenient but like you would survive
no I would spend 1 hour at the Beverly
Center and I would would be completely
fine a Bloomingdale's a Macy's like
please yeah Ben will be fine and he
loves to shop loves now I want to
preface that I'm not sick and I'm not
crying either but you
are horse and dig you Jewel no wow so
what's the point of not jeweling if
you're still going to get a horse voice
I just spent like the whole weekend
screaming and not getting a lot of sleep
you know yeah hold on I'm like really
not okay are you sticky shoes have you
given it a spin honestly I'm a little
far gone Sticky Shoes like I just sound
bad we'll we'll take a
listen
Okay my Sticky Sticky Shoes it's pretty
good it's giving like Louis
Armstrong right it is giving Louis
Armstrong oh my God I'm deceased and a
half and I know everyone's like Claudia
you were on vacation in Mexico how do
you come back more tired this was not an
ordinary trip like it wasn't relaxing in
the
slightest I'm overloaded candy CED my
life's impling now I'm good and broken
oh okay I was like what are you
overloaded with but yes I understand no
I'm good and broken I understand you're
good and broken well that's good it
looks like you had a jolly good time I
had a blast like seriously this is the
price that you pay I yeah I'm sorry to
say like we don't feel sorry no I'm not
looking for some I am not looking for
I cannot stress out enough like no I'm
not looking for sympathy I'm just deeply
unw tell us about your trip it was
amazing my friend Crystal throws every
year like a major birthday party for
herself but it's really like not for her
it's for everyone cuz like I feel like
we all have more fun than her because
we're just like enjoying and she's
planning for everyone and this year was
no different this is like my fifth year
going she's such a [__] Legend and
she just like went all out it was like 4
days just party party party and like so
many of her friends from my life who are
my friends from my like I got to see and
I never get to see them got to meet new
people I met tanks like I met tanks and
let me tell you we know tell us
everything I'm obsessed you have a new
best friend is my I don't think I
feeling you're you're out you out I'm
out for 2024 Jackie out 2024 out Tins in
tinks is in but like I wouldn't say
we're best friends cuz like I'm obsessed
with her like she probably thinks I'm a
freak you know you don't think she's
going on her podcast today talking about
you
honestly she might yeah it just depends
you know what she likes to talk about
right right right her personal life and
of course yeah I actually feel like on
her podcast like she helps other people
with like their problems it's more like
advice than like here's what I do this
it's hey look at me you know you you
could write into her podcast if you need
some friendly advice hey I met this
girl no I just had the best time like
the weather was perfect I really worked
so hard on my outfits cuz Crystal themes
every night so the themes were like
disco uh Playboy club and like white
party so you have to and everybody
really does the most so you don't want
to be someone who's like just wearing
something from Amazon you know you have
to like really work hard I spent like
two weeks on my outfits I feel like I
really crushed it in every sense and I
just had so much fun I'm like so upset
that it's over and I don't know what to
do like I'll never be the same well
don't cry because it's over smile
because it happened so true and look
back on the
memories in the words of Fallout Boy
Thanks for the
Memories thanks Crystal and tinks yeah
literally no I had so much
fun worth like what I'm experiencing
right now you know yeah and
I that's it like that's it great well
we're happy to have you back how was
your long weekend it was lovely it was
really a nice weekend spent with family
and friends quite different from yours
but no no I mean it was I was with I was
with family and friends too tinks is
like family
um no but it was really nice it was nice
to be all from the show missed the show
missed Y gires and a lot happened a lot
did happen so we we'll get into it in
the stories I finished the crown which
was spoil it really ex don't spoil it it
was really a highlight of my weekend I
have to say I texted you cuz I just
thoroughly enjoyed this season and we
have a CRA uh Royal story so I'll put
some of my thoughts in there and then
when you finish we can do a whole thing
because it was just to Delight so we
have a royal story do we also have
Christen juice Che story course the name
on everybody's lips this weekend was
Christen juice check the name on
everybody's lips this weekend was
Christian juuse check use check she's in
the running for Queenie of the week she
by the way we totally forgot to do
weenie of the week last week I know we
have to like set a reminder maybe it'll
be bi-weekly it's like not in our DNA
yet like dear toaster like I wake up on
Wednesday and I know yeah this is so new
like of course we forgot the second time
we were supposed to do it like we're
we'll get our sea leg soon yeah she is
in the running for Queenie of the week I
have to like also start keeping it top
of mind for me like when we're talking
about people or just when I'm
experiencing things yeah well also with
a W show right now like it's ripe with
fodder for weenie and Queenie my Queenie
of the week is probably tinks your
Queenie of the Year Queenie of my life
that's so crazy I feel like
that's what's it like it's like Sweet
Life on Deck of Hannah Montana yes yes
that's so sweet life that's so sweet
life of Hannah Montana it's um that's
what it is it's the crossover of a
generation I just feel like she's like
West Coast tury like we're two girls
with nicknames we're like Millennial
icons like I really feel I really feel
that way do you find that you guys are
really similar or you are like magnets
and you're attracted because your of
your differences I actually don't think
we're similar at all except that like we
both share this sort of love and
Obsession for gossip you know yeah yeah
but that's like a universal whole thing
yeah but on a personal
level on a personality level actually no
I feel like we're really like twin
flames but in a similar way or in an
attracted way I don't know like the
these questions are too deep like we
just got along you know no but I'm
asking like was she boisterous like
turty or did she balance tury was she
boisterous like turty I don't know I'm
like forgetting I'm like blacking out
cuz it was like too much um no she's
boisterous she's boisterous and but
she's different cuz like we're both
funny
but I'm like absurdly funny and like
like a little wild funny and she's like
very smart funny actually she kind of
reminds me of you which is perhaps why
we got along so well I knew there was a
compliment in there for me somewhere
yeah she's like witty like you know she
went to like grad school yeah what did
she
study fashion right Journal
journalism awesome yeah like real like
and she went to Stanford like smart
smart and she's like decided to use her
talents like for humor you like your
friend smart
yeah I do you surround yourself with
smart people do I I feel like yeah I
feel like you high school friends are
smart yeah they are they
are maybe I'm just like a smart person
who lifts up other smart people you are
what you attract what are they what's
the saying I don't chase I attract what
is mine will find me that like doesn't
really work here also in the crown the
queen kind of like told William like a
line that came right out of Tik Tok say
it like that sometimes happens I'll be
watching show I'm like they didn't talk
like that but she said what's did she
say William you are giving main
character energy she might as well she
said William what's meant for you won't
pass you
by okay that's like not that Tik Tock
but when she said it it made sense like
it was only after that I'm like oh
that's like what they say um that's
meant for me will find me yeah it does
sound like that classic chant yeah the
manifestation yeah what's meant for me
will find me but of course the queen
made it just
exceptional on a totally separate note
on my flight home yesterday I unfollowed
almost 100 people poor k i just like was
getting a little out of control like a
little willy-nilly with like my follows
you know and I felt like my feed was
filled with people I didn't want to
[__] see yeah and it just got me
thinking because before I would unfollow
someone especially if they like followed
me back I would be like oh this is like
going to start a problem they're going
to think I'm like mad at them or I don't
like them and that's just not the case
you know like not everyone's content is
going to serve you at all different
times of your life you know who were the
kinds of people that you want followed
influencers celebrities or friends
former like you know old high school
people no no no I didn't I didn't follow
you really can't those people who you
follow like you're locked in for life I
didn't not follow anyone from like high
school or college like it was
influencers SBS content creators like
people with platforms drop of names and
so like some of them I followed because
they followed me and I was like oh
that's cool and that's like what we call
mutuals you know but then I was just
like this content doesn't serve me and
so I posted this thing on my Instagram
being like why can't we start like
unfollowing people and not have it mean
something like I don't hate you it's
just like your content's not for me and
you wouldn't want to hit them with the
mute so then everyone was like I totally
agree with this but then that's why the
mute button but then I'm like okay we're
really going to like be like so phony
and keep up appearances because we don't
want because you just don't want to
follow someone and we're going to tiptoe
around people's feelings like maybe like
like I I don't know I just don't agree
like with with babying everyone and
what's the kind of content that no
longer serves you did you notice a theme
is it people who are like what are they
doing question that's an amazing
question well I just think like I
followed a lot of people who were like
at the time when I followed them like
really relevant in the culture like they
were on a Netflix show and then you
became obsessed you followed and now
it's like I Don't Care What They're by
way exactly
understood you want to name names or no
no but like if you notice that I
unfollowed you you're one of the hundred
like just know like I still have love in
my heart for you it's really like it's
not that deep I think we really need to
like desensitize ourselves to being
unfollowed and then somebody messaged me
and she like agreed with me she was like
no tury I totally feel this like I
literally unfollowed you last year cuz
like your content didn't serve me
anymore and then I became a toaster so I
ref followed you and like now I'm loving
it I was like okay wait this can't apply
to me wait a jam minut but no like she's
right
yeah that hurts though it hurts when
it's like coming back she threw that
[__] back in my face
yeah but she's not wrong yeah but if
you're going to do it you have to be
able to accept it as well so my heart
goes out to The
100 the 100 Fallen
follows and like maybe our like we will
be reunited We Salute You thank you for
your
service not everything is meant to last
forever you know yeah so what like who
else Vibes no and then I just like then
I was like looking at people who like
followed 3,000 people just like I was
checking I'm like oh does this person
still follow me cuz if they do like
maybe I won follow and I'm like wow you
follow 4,000 people like you have no
Scruples like you have no standards so
many people no point where you worried
about your number or like your ratio
which like a ratio is not a thing when
you have 3 million followers no no no no
but like I don't I was like I think I
was at like 650 and what are you at now
like
550 right because you want followed 100
right I just feel like 650 is like a lot
of people to be following I need to look
at mine now oh and by the way Instagram
has this new thing Jackie Jackie Jackie
look at me go to who you're following
and they tell you who you least interact
with yes anel elwart was my number one
least interacted I didn't even know that
I followed him oh my least interacted
Elsa Hosk see like that's weird that you
follow her now she has good style and
pleasant content I feel like I see it
all the time how is she my least
interacted
with I like that they like let me know
who I don't I've see I've seen this a
lot but it's like there's a reason I
don't interact with them but I don't
mind following them well I found that
little tab extremely helpful in the you
know the hund yeah I follow what did I
say 650 649 I'm I'm okay with that but I
want to continue to be like fast and
loose with my follows so I had to make
some room you know yeah so you do care
about the number just a little bit not
so much like Margot is obsessed with 500
if she meets someone new and wants to
follow them she will go find someone
else to unfollow to go to $4.99 and then
go to 500 to follow that new person like
that's sick she's
Cutthroat like I feel like that's nuts
you know like I don't want to limit the
amount of love I can receive you know
but I got a little out of
control okay well I don't think there
should really be a limit I mean I guess
if you're following in the thousands
it's like do we mean nothing to you
right but I feel like up until a
thousand yeah there's room what are your
thoughts on unfollowing people who have
passed
away you just have to like rip it off
like a Band-Aid and I feel like if it's
close if it's someone you know like I
feel like it's impossible to do but when
it's a celebrity like you just kind of
have to like look away and unfollow and
then move on yeah like I did not
unfollow Virgil
ablo but mostly because he before he
passed followed me so does the estate of
Virgil ablo use his account no it's like
it's not act in this SL yeah got it cuz
sometimes the estate then is like the
right no no no for a while like Melissa
Rivers was um updating joanes Instagram
yeah I think that you can unfollow
obviously it's not like the minute they
die rip
unfollow yeah but as you comb through
your followers oh this person has
passed and so will I going to do like a
quick
unfollow painful yeah it's a weird thing
yeah it is but so it's more personal
than comedy it is well I just wanted to
put that out there if if you're part of
the 100 I love you still like maybe
they'll start a support group or like a
hate page for me well they could just
Join one yeah it's so true you don't
need to build it if you build it they
will come so we've got a great show I'm
like lit for the stories yeah we could
get into the stories it's time because
we're recording late today and we've got
to get the people the episode oh yeah I
apologize today's episode is out far
later than our usual time like your girl
needed to sleep
yeah so without further ad did it did
Ado here are the fast five stories that
you need to know and the fast five
stories that you need to know are
brought to you by hinge hinge is the
dating app that's designed to be deleted
why Bill hinge gives you a sense of
someone's personality and lets you share
your own you get to know potential dates
through their unique answers to prompts
plus you get a sense of someone's dating
intentions and what they're looking for
I feel like everyone knows like if
you're serious about dating like you're
looking for a real relationship hinge is
a place to go and we're actually sitting
down with um kind of a hinge celect
celebrity yes yes my big interview I met
my husband on hinge well thanks to hinge
is how we got together and we would
probably not be together at least in the
time frame that we were together without
hinge and I recommend everyone go on
hinge anyone who asked me for dating
advice they want to settle down they
want to be in a relationship I'm like
get on hinge first of all you need to be
on the apps you need to get out there
but hinge is the app for serious people
who want serious relationships yeah so
download hinge and find someone who's
worth deleting the app for I feel like a
lot of people's resolutions is like
getting serious about dating or if they
like have been through a breakup and
they haven't been able to put themselves
out there now is like the time of year
where they really want to get started
again and I love this like I love that
Hing is running our ads with us in
January because it's the perfect time to
get back on the app get more serious
about it and commit yourself to like
being in a relationship this year I love
that yeah you could be serious by summer
and have a I'm just a summer girl I wear
my flipflops and have your boyfriend and
have a boyfriend over the like a
boyfriend in the summer greater than not
having a Bo summer spending the holidays
together are we getting engaged I don't
know hopefully today's episode is
brought to you by Legacy box as well so
if you grew up in a similar time frame
that Jackie and I did you have like a
big fat stack of VHS tapes in your
basement in your attic like probably
being destroyed because you don't even
know like your basement is flooded some
people grew up in like a camcorder reels
era like we were VHS girlies and the
amount of money like we had spent over
the years like trying to get these vhs's
transferred into like something we could
possibly watch them on is so dumb Legacy
box came in change the game they make
digitizing your old home videos and
tapes so so easy simply send your legacy
box filled with camcorder tapes film
reels pictures and get back digital
copies that can be easily enjoyed shared
and organized it's literally like magic
and when you go to legacybox.com toast
you can enjoy 50% off when you get
started with Legacy box today the
process is super easy fill it up with
the tapes they do VHS they do camcorder
they do old pictures and their team will
professionally digitize everything by
hand it's all done in the US and you'll
get it back on the cloud or a thumb
drive along with your Originals we got a
thumb drive so easy we just did um was
it your and Olivia's bot Mitzvah Montage
yes you guys it was so major we we
watched it we were like crying laughing
it was just the best such a good gift
too for someone in your life like a
grandparent or a sibling so kick off
your parents cuz your parents were the
ones who filmed all of it kick off the
New Year by rescuing your family's most
cherished memories that haven't been
watched or enjoyed in years go to
legacybox.com toast 50% off by today
send in when you're ready go to
legacybox.com toast legacybox.com
toast thank you la you're welcome our
first story the name on everybody's lips
this weekend Kristen yusek the wife of
49er star Kyle yuse designed a custom
coat for tailored Swift to wear to the
freezing cold Kansas City chief game and
Taylor it was one of her best looks ever
everyone was like who made that coat and
Kyle yek was going to let you know that
it was his wife if you didn't already
follow her but now I think around
500,000 so let me tell you how this
weekend like so many people discovered
oh Kyle yusek has a wife who's really
really talented and beautiful and like
has a great Instagram and they all
started following her if you're a
toaster you already knew that like you
were kind of ahead of the game we talk
about Christen use Che all the time she
is a toaster uh she's the best and she's
always like posting really cute reals
she like goes vintage shopping finds
like old cuz her husband plays on the
49ers these old like jackets and jerseys
and she totally reworks them into like a
pair of boots like it's insane what she
does yeah like every Sunday when she
goes to her husband's game she wears
like a fit that she designed herself
made from like reworked vintage jerseys
or just regular jerseys like always
something so sickening and then in the
last few weeks she's been making for
other people too Simone biles wore one
of her vest right when Simone biles wore
and like ordered from her like it was
such a big deal and Britney momes had
worn something by her and then this
weekend both taylored and Britney wore
coats with their husband's jerseys
designed by Kristen and because it was
like the coldest game ever it was like3
de so all eyes were on the jackets like
what is Taylor going to wear and she
just wore one of her best outfits period
to the games and everyone was like who's
that girl it's Kristen and I'm just
obsessed with like monitoring how it's
impacting Christen new check before this
Saga she had 113,000 followers as of
this very moment she has 520,000 like
that's insane wow that's amazing also
they're going doubly viral because her
husband Kyle is commenting on every post
about Taylor's jacket being like made by
the great Christen new Che that's my
girl he was not he was not going to let
any Taylor Swift fan account any major
media's news account he was not going to
let them talk about Taylor Swift's
outfit without giving credit to his wife
and we stand We Stand yeah so now he's
going viral for being just like a
support
and it's a beautiful beautiful story and
I really hope that it leads to like
chrenek should be designing like women's
apparel for nfl.com right so a lot of
people are like wanting to place orders
but she doesn't like own a company it's
really virtually impossible to sell
um sportsare like with NFL logos on it
because of the licensing they do not let
anyone anyone do that she just makes
stuff for herself and for her friends so
it's not like a business but everyone's
like please like start a start a
business she literally can't right but
they should hire her if they're smart so
the NFL should really hire her as like a
creative director of their merch cuz
like I feel like the website for women's
like if you try and buy a women's
t-shirt disgusting just the shape of it
I wonder if they've reached out like at
all I should ask her but there's yeah
let's manifest it yeah like she needs a
gig like there is work for her to be
there's work to be done like the NFL
merch is horrible especially for women
yeah yeah and now that we're all
obsessed with football like we'd like a
little something to wear no it's true
somebody really should like jump on this
like Fanatics that company like they
sell merch too like somebody yeah needs
to jump on and like bring her on as like
a designer yeah 100% also tailored lner
was wearing her jacket the next night to
the Detroit Lions game it was larv ver
debt it was LV ver debt and we need to
talk about football because a lot is
going on first is that the Eagles lost
last night yeah well we have an eagle
story so save your thoughts on the
Eagles second is that the Cowboys lost
so momentously it was a suppressing
evening in my house who do they lose to
the
Packers oh right and now the Niners are
playing the Packers yeah it was really
sad and I just I kept asking Zach all
these hypothetical questions and like he
was literally like go away shut up [__]
no he didn't say that he was just like
oh my God he wasn't okay I didn't think
he actually said it he wasn't verbally
abusive he was just like well that's
good that is good thank you that's good
I was like would you rather lose by so
much you sound annoying like you do you
s would you rather would you rather lose
by so much like there was no chance of
winning it's a good question oh oh okay
thanks or like when it's the tightest
game and end like they pull out a
touchdown and you were so close to
winning like I feel like that's more
frustrating it's worse I would rather
lose by like 50 yeah where there was
like no other parallel universe where we
win yeah no I agree with you that's a
good question but still it was really it
it was also sad cuz I felt like we were
saying how the Cowboys like weren't a
good enough team to be in the playoffs
and like right that proved that like
they could not hold their own whatsoever
so what you're saying is like we are
analysts oh for sure well we're
analyzing whether it's good or bad we
are analyzing I do feel like it's really
important and a lot of people like
especially from the debt area are really
mad at us because we talk so much about
football like who we think and we've
really I don't even think we've uttered
the words Detroit L on this show and
they're amazing like they really are but
like in my mind and especially in like
how the NFL and the teams like relate to
the culture I honestly the Detroit Lions
like might as well be invisible like I
don't give the Detroit Lions a first
thought let alone a second thought I
could go years without ever thinking
about the Detroit Lions no and honestly
if I didn't follow Taylor and Taylor
lner on Instagram like I might not even
know that J trit had a team like that's
how irrelevant they really are but one
thing that is in their column that I now
know is that they're a team with a vowel
in the middle of their acronym thus
making them the debt so I just really
want to quickly look something up
because I think I really truly stand by
the fact especially now that the Eagles
lost because in order to make the Super
Bowl the 49ers would have had to have
beat beat beaten the Eagles and they
lost to them last year so I really I do
firmly believe that the Niners are going
to be playing the Ravens in the Super
Bowl like that's what I think I think
that's a really good guess and then
maybe debt will be in the semi seminal
so that's what I was I wanted to know
like how the debt team like plays into
this like what division they're in Oh
They'll be their own Conference
champions but who do they have to go up
against the 49ers or the
Ravens wait what it's a hard question
take your time which conference what's
their name
Lions
yeah the lions are in NFC North okay and
then search what the 49ers are in
and God forbid it was just like East
vers West no and there's eight divisions
God forid we could look at a map of
America and no okay NFC West no wait
sorry okay lions are NFC North Niners
are NFC West okay so they'll have to
play each other for the NFC
Championship yeah I guess that makes
sense to me and if that's wrong then it
just doesn't make
sense cuz
AFC and I was saying this yesterday to
my close personal friend chrris news
check um cuz we were just talking about
like how amazing like what's happening
and I said
like good things happen to people in
waves like you have like a really good
year you know and I just feel like
between the Taylor Swift effect and the
49ers like just being so good I really
feel like the 49ers could like I feel I
feel like this it's their time I really
the juju is strong and like for Olivia
Christian getting engaged and they're
getting married soon like there's just
so many Simas for the 49ers no I really
truly honestly believe it's their time
Nick Bosa being in a skims campaign when
it rains it pours
huge huge
thighs I think it's their time too I do
I really really do and that's not just
because obviously like we're close
personal friends with so many of the you
know players it has nothing to do with
that like I really the toast is kind of
the official podcast of the 49ers for
sure when I was in Mexico this weekend
on Sunday like during the day they set
up like a big TV so everybody could
watch the games and you know I was like
chatting football with some folks and I
was like oh who's your your team and
they were like who's your team and I
said the 49ers and they were like oh are
you from the Bay Area I'm like no
they're like so why the 49ers and like I
just I just I had to say like I'm the
official podcast of the 49ers yeah it's
the
most toasters per density per capita per
capita in the locker room exactly and
that and I feel like debt has the least
honestly debt has the least exactly
they're in debt
to
us sorry to our all our Lions fans yeah
it's on your time but you know what it
might be what we used to say was in
49ers time and look at us singing a
different tune exactly we have like a
pretty good sort of gauge on these types
of things yeah and the Kansas City
Chiefs won their game yeah who' they
play bills no no bills played last
they're playing bills next that's going
to be a hard game by the way like I
think the Chiefs and the bills it's
anyone's game because I think the Chiefs
oh the Chiefs played the Dolphins which
was impossible ne30 degrees the Dolphins
playing the Heat the Chiefs are used to
the cold I also saw a real About
Dolphins stadium the way that it was
built is that the Sun Shines on the
opposing team side the entire game they
have sun in their eyes and they're
hotter than the other side where it's
Shady um okay that's giving like cheater
it's giving homec corn Advantage wait
that's like really low-key crazy cuz
like it kind of reminds me of like when
the Patriots were deflating those balls
like a sort like a very small detail but
it is considered cheating okay no but
like it's not they well I guess I by way
I don't know if I believe that because
games are at 1 4 or eight like the sun
is at a different spot well between 1
and four but it's still coming in at an
angle or it's overhead I'm just telling
you what I saw in the real okay the real
and then they don't play the second half
of the Year where the sun's like on the
other side of the world I'm not buying
it I'm not buying it let me Google it
Dolphin Stadium
Sun Dolphin Stadium Sun
Sabotage by the way
title
Love say that
again hotter it's 30 degrees hotter on
the other side she's yeah okay okay wow
wow so I what like that to me is such an
extreme I feel like if the Chiefs and
the fins had played in Florida the
Dolphins would have won I'm sorry the
chief and the who the fins that's what
we call them down here and you know we
say Fins Up Fins Up okay Alex Earl okay
Centura literally it's giving Dan Marino
and the dolin yeah but those are two
teams with that play in extreme weather
and and that's a real homec corn
Advantage so that's why the Chiefs
versus Bills will be interesting because
they're both cold weather players you're
so right and they're doing it in Buffalo
it's and there's a blizzard here
like interesting also it's kind of like
celebrity spouse vers celebrity spouse
cuz let's me not forget Josh Allen is
dating the beautiful haly Stein and
they're like really lowkey serious and
I'm obsessed yeah and it's like is
taylored going to watch with her former
friend Haley oh by the way totally
forgot about like the history between
those two oh my god do you know what
tinx told me what and like it was a fact
about Taylor Swift that like I didn't
know okay there was like a very brief
period like maybe a week back in the day
where Taylor Swift dated Evan Spiegel
did you know that
no is that crazy that's a fun fact yeah
tinks was full of them oh I'm sure tinks
this tinks that what about me I feel
like all we talk about is tins these
days anyways tinks and Kristen use check
sounds about right okay like circling
back so happy for Christen use check
seriously seriously and the cream always
Rises you guys it's so true are you
ready for our next story more football
news yes Jason Kelce tells his teammates
that he's retiring from the NFL after 13
Seasons with the Eagles so the Eagles
lost last night and Jason announced to
his teammates in the locker room that he
will be
retiring so obviously it's not a great
way to go out losing in the first round
of the playoffs especially when you made
it to the Super Bowl last year and I'm
sure part of him last year was like if I
win the Super Bowl I will retire if I
don't I'll try one more time now do you
think it's better to have gone out like
at the end of a season where you lose in
the superl
or to go out at the end of a season
where you lose in the first round of the
playoffs it would have been a nicer
story if it was last season it was like
him versus his brother even though he
lost I don't think of it as a loss
because like there's nothing
more of a win than playing in the Super
Bowl against your brother and like that
it was all about his family but I feel
like athletes and just you know people
in general just have a hard time like
going out on top because they think
there's more decline know and the timing
is really really hard and I just Googled
it because I wanted to make sure um like
like if he's ever won a Super Bowl and
he has he won once since remember oh you
didn't watch their documentary yet and
he gave that big speech about hungry
dogs oh no I actually really do need to
watch that stupid ass documentary like
you don't let me say it's probably way
easier to like consider retiring um when
you have such a huge career outside of
football like between the podcast and
like him just being like really a
celebrity both in Philly but everywhere
too it's probably a lot easier to
reconcile like the loss of income with
the idea that you actually probably are
now open to way more opportunities I'm
sure he would not have a hard time
getting like a big broadcasting contract
oh yeah people love him for him I don't
think it's about the revenue he like if
you watch the documentary I don't think
you need to do like he's really normal
yeah not about that I'm sure he has more
money than he'll ever need and the
podcast is really he's got a career and
it is nice to not like worry what your
next job is going to be but he also has
like a lot of investments in the um yeah
he does a lot of different things he
stays busy and then of course his music
career yeah I'm sure he'll continue to
do stuff like that and he really is a
celebrity I mean he's a celebrity period
but he's like the mayor of Philadelphia
yeah he's like a real like a leader in
his community he is and he takes that
seriously so there's a lot waiting for
him but I'm sure it's hard and you know
when you're an athlete like it's not
just you played in the NFL like your
entire life life it's so true your
entire life waking up workouts ice bath
cold
plunge yeah but then it's like the first
time that for a lot of them that they
get to spend like a serious amount of
time with their kids yeah but then you
watch Tyson Fury's documentary and you
got to get back out there it's too much
time with your kids it's that's true
yeah I think it's hard for people who
are like going going going going to stop
or slow down even and it really it
wasn't a great year for the Eagles I
feel like they started out really on top
and just slowly slowly like they
couldn't get their act together and they
kind of were just this discombobulated
mess yeah but maybe he'll come back like
Tom Brady Style no he's like a
like Jason serious when he says
something he means it yeah and this is
not a decision he takes slightly I'm
sure yeah I don't think he's coming back
no but that's what happens it's really
hard to slow down and then they're like
well maybe I should just play more it's
also weird like because the Kelsey
family are from Ohio like that's their
home but he spent 13 years in Philly
like do you stay in
Philly I saw something but nothing
reputable nor that I clicked it might
have just been like a Facebook you know
one of those like fake headlines to get
you to click about how he's moving out
of Philly it's fake yeah like how would
we know that and where does Donna
live I feel like she lives in Philly too
but also his wife is a Philly girl I
think they'll stay and like the kids
have lived there for 13 years well not
13 but you know what I mean like they're
in school and stuff yeah I think that
they will stay there even though the
family should be together I feel like
he's kind of GNA become to the Eagles
but Tony Romo is to the Cowboys you know
yes an elder Statesman an elder
Statesman and he is the Like official
broadcaster for a certain Network when
the Cowboys play oh that's why I'm to me
Tony Romo is always the broadcasting no
because you only watch Cowboys gam in
your house interesant yeah oh you know
what Zach told me a fun fact what fun
fact that for the last two years the
color of the Super Bowl logo has wound
up being the team colors that played and
it's Ravens and ners this year and it's
RAV ners this year ra that's kind of
weird it's cuz the NFL is scripted the
NFL is
scripted who am I Cowboys Harry yeah
Harry's favorite word is Cowboys because
Zach is like infiltrating and making
sure that Harry grows up knowing like
this is a cowboy house and anytime you
see someone playing a sport or literally
the color blue all football to him is
Cowboys Cowboys and it was funny because
when the when Dallas lost um I was like
well Harry said the Cowboys lost L and
he was like no cuz to him the green
Cowboys won right right they're all
Cowboys they're all I mean they are all
Cowboys and I mean I think we're all
Cowboys I think we all want to be
Cowboys I don't even know if the Cowboys
want to be Cowboys you know anything can
happen no it's so true and to make the
playoffs really it's like an honor to be
nominated yeah yeah came
further right as long as you're always
getting better yeah but it's time for
you know a serious change I have no idea
what what needs to change I think maybe
Jason Kelsey needs to take his talents
to to Dallas maybe a new coach I don't
know who the coach is no actually I was
reading something about a general
manager yeah oh they the Cowboys don't
have one because Jerry takes it on and I
trust Jerry I just want to say like I
look at Jerry and I say that man knows
what he's doing but the fans like who
are upset with the lack of progress they
say we want a GM now I don't really know
what a manager is gonna do like on the
field I just think don't you need like
better players but maybe I just don't
know enough about football also it's
like okay Dallas didn't go where they
wanted to go but it's not like they were
last like why do they need to upheave
their entire system but the Jets don't
like please okay right like they did
okay they me to the playoffs the middle
of the
pack they don't need full upheaval just
like and they had a winning record they
were like 12 and four that's we'll do
better next year yeah doesn't mean it
needs to be a referendum on Jerry no
it's so true like leave Jerry
alone leave Jerry alone leave him alone
are you ready for our next story what
number is this three three sorry Trace
yeah we always like to inject a little
Spanish on the show I literally like I'm
Spanish L right no and everyone thinks
I'm Spanish cuz cloudia is like a Latin
name and I feel like actually I am
okay like when I like when I was INX
Rachel doal yeah F you're
Hilaria yes but my name is actually
Claudia you're Claudia Baldwin I guess
it would be like the equivalent of me
like introducing myself as Claudia yeah
that's Hillary Hilaria Claudia Claudia
no but you didn't have to change any
letters you didn't have to change any
Morgan letters it's true it's just my
intonation yeah
tell think
abouta our next story is just a little
award show recap from the weekend
because there were many award shows that
took place last night was the
Emy then there was the critic's choice
which apparently like we all watch now
okay Chelsea Handler hosted that emy's
was a no host situation I didn't watch
yeah obviously like hosting is kind of
the name on everyone's lips that's like
why people are tuning in and I think a
lot of people actually did tune in to
the Critics Choice Awards one because it
was the first show after the Golden
Globes and like you wanted to compare
hosts and of course Chelsey hler and Joe
Koy dated very seriously for like two
years and the fact that they did
back-to-back award shows and one of them
flopped like people wanted to see what
she would do battle of the ex's now I
watched her monologue it was like
harmless it was funny like she just did
the job you know is it going to be
talked about for years no but she did a
good job she didn't yell at anyone she
didn't have a breakdown and people for
the most part seem to really like her
jokes like in the audience they were
having a good time yeah now of course
like it just makes a whole jokoy thing
like even worse like your ex-girlfriend
like could do it and you couldn't you
know yeah and it's just I toy between
being like it's a thankless job
everybody hates you no matter what you
do and also being like a thankless job
try coal mining all you have to do is
tell a couple jokes and that's your
trade you just have to make people laugh
you have endless fodder you're on a huge
stage you it's a great plat platform to
launch yourself especially anyone would
kill for that opportunity what are you
doing complaining true no it's so true
and and if it's really so hard like hit
the mines Co mine a Cole mine a
Cole yeah right like I go back and forth
yeah no I when I first came on this show
to recap jooy my mindset was like it's a
thankless job like people just should
have laughed and like moved on but then
you were really put everything in
perspective like it's actually probably
the best job in the world
it's a job where you have an entire team
of writers so if you don't want to write
jokes like you don't have to the best
joke wins two it's a the hardest part of
doing standup is memorizing your jokes
and writing your jokes two things you
don't have to do when you have a gig
like this you have a teleprompter and
you have a team of writers you get like
full Glam like it sounds amazing
actually and it's a platform for
literally someone like Joe Koy who maybe
not everyone tuning in knew of it's like
the biggest stage so I actually my mind
completely changed and I agree with you
thank you so yeah that's where I've
landed and now it's just like a word
show season there were a couple standout
moments from the Emmys sui Waterhouse
arrived bumping to the
gods bumping to the gods yeah uh
Christina Applegate received a standing
ovation as a presenter made some jokes
she's a queen she's a queen she said it
was a bless for everybody to be giving
her a standing ovation because she can't
stand without a cane like obsessed yeah
it's like that's and also she didn't
write that joke cuz she didn't know they
would all be standing so that's just
like someone being funny yeah then she
was like sorry my body's not biosic cuz
I think like the illness that she has
like makes you gain weight and she's
just like lean she's just leaning in
like whatever yeah and like she was
being funny off the cuff improv Queen
like we stand there was also drama
between Bella Ramy and Ariana de from
The critic's Choice
Awards yeah it's giving like major loser
un loser crime I don't care yeah and you
know the stars were out I that was
really I didn't watch either of them so
I really I'm so sorry like not doing my
job as a pop culture commentator but um
no we watched that other one yeah I feel
like the Golden Globes was like enough
for me to I know I'll watch the Oscars
and the
Grammys yeah I feel like critic's choice
is definitely not required viewing and
the Emmys really aren't either yeah
there were some nice looks though
everyone's been looking nice lately and
I appreciate that by the way did you see
what happened to Kelty night on the red
carpet that she lost her diamond yeah
her Diamond four karat diamond like fell
out of the setting of her ring and like
she literally hasn't found it damn she's
not going to I'm sure she has it inured
but like that sucks yeah that really
does dang oh my God I totally forgot to
wear my rings today I am still married
just wanted to say I don't know he was
spotted with a woman's Luggage in
Nordstrom he was spotted shopping in
Nordstrom with a bag full of
bikinis it's true I no comment are you
ready for our next
story
no no you don't look ready so I'll let
you get ready okay hold on I'm I'm
really not ready take your time
La these next two stories are brought to
you by deral logica specifically the
daily microfoliant which is a favorite
among fans of the brand so it's
activated with water if you are into
exfoliating which I'm obsessed with
exfoliating my face I happen to love the
daily microfoliant from Dermalogica it's
not like others you know you like mix it
you feel like a chemist you like it's
like this little powder and it's kind of
grainy yes you add water and like mix it
up in your hands and then it becomes
like foamy and stuff um and it's safe to
use every day so I really love to
exfoliate my face but a lot of them are
really harsh and you can't do it more
than like twice a week the daily
microlon is suitable for all skin types
even sensitive skin and some of the
benefits are improved skin smoothness
you can reduce blackheads it visibly
brightens skin minimizes the look of
dark spots so Dermalogica is a
professional great skincare brain brand
whose products are designed to treat
your unique skin concerns I feel like
dermica is just a brand that's trusted
so whatever it is that you need I trust
dermica Brands like whenever I need a
new cleanser or whatever it is like I go
there and I happen to love the daily
microlon and that's how I learned about
the brand because it kind of went viral
on Tik Tok and everybody was talking
about it so that's how I eventually you
know got involved so visit
dermalogica.com for more information and
a free gift with a $2 or more purchase
at checkout so Dermalogica is spelled D
e r m a l o g i ca.com so visit
dermalogica.com for more information and
a free gift with $20 or more purchase at
checkout today's episode is also brought
to you by skims skims is creating the
next generation of underwear and bras
for everybody so there's so many
collections that I feel like go really
viral but currently I'm in my fits
everybody collection my favorite bras
are from the fits everybody collection I
love everything from this collection
it's so wellmade it's the best T-shirt
bra I've owned I wear it every day it
comes in by the way I feel like skims is
everybody talks like all about skes but
they don't talk about how every one of
their products comes in like a thousand
colors yeah it's not just beige it's
sand like they have like a thousand
different beiges top and then a thousand
different blacks you really do need Onyx
I love Onyx that's my favorite color I
feel like you really do need like so
many different colors of underwear and
bras for different outfits and they
really under they get it so the fits
everybody T-shirt bra is a favorite of
Jackie and I if you have like real
breasts you know like women's breasts
breasts that maybe don't stand up on
their own all the time breasts that
maybe hurt your back breasts that need a
hand breasts that need a helping hand
that skims should use as their slogan
they're made with Innovative technology
they give you the best shape and support
every bra is designed with the comfiest
softest material so you feel like you're
wearing nothing at all and they're bras
are available in 62 sizes they go from
30A to 46h believe the hype skims has
over 1,000 festar reviews for a reason
there skims bras are now available at
skims.com plus get free shipping on
orders of over $75 if you haven't yet be
sure to let them know that the toast
sent you after you placed your order
select podcast in the survey and select
our show in the drop- down menu that
follows and if you're looking for a gift
for your for Valentine's Day for
yourself skims just launched their best
Valentine's shop ever also available at
skims.com great thank you before we get
to the last two stories two bits of news
that I just when I checked my phone I
saw one Kylie dyed her hair pink oh I
know I'm obsessed yeah what you're not
no I mean I love everything she does but
just I didn't I feel like it's in
congruous to this era that she's in of
just being like kind of like Demir
Timothy's lady oh I totally disagree it
cuz I feel like while yes she's been
dressing like very Demir Timothy's lady
she's just kind of in this like free era
you know what I mean she just doing
whatever the [__] she wants like going
to the Emmys and being on TV for three
hours like that's not something she
would ever do and I love like I I first
of all I loved that King Kylie era where
she wore wigs and had different colored
hair all the time like that was so
iconic and now it's like more mature
King Kylie era I love it no it's
exciting and I I'll change I'd love to
see it and I look forward to following
her in this journey I hope it's not just
like a wig for a shoot and then like
tomorrow she's back to the black of hair
it it did not look like a wig but her
wigs never do right so we'll see what
was the second piece of news oh
something that I've been obsessed with
all weekend that I know you don't care
about but I'm sure there are people out
there who do is ballerina Farm has given
birth she gave birth two weeks ago but
she's also hosting the Miss America
pageant in Las Vegas and this this woman
is not real like went on a ballerina
Farm stalking Rampage the other day this
woman deserves a Nobel Peace Prize like
she just gave birth she has seven
children she makes her own food and
kills her own game and she is hosting
Miss Universe She Looks un Mrs America
she looks unreal she's just not real I
feel like she has eight kids cuz I
stalked her and then I stalked her
husband and his bios a father of eight
maybe was seven going on eight right she
gave birth at home no medication like
she's just not a real person okay also I
want to talk about ballerina Farm I
would I could talk all day about
ballerina farm and I'm glad that you're
in the mix no because I was little I was
I was reading this article about her and
you know how like when anybody
especially like a digital person mostly
a woman has like a scandal attached to
them they absolutely like have to
reference it in the first sentence of
the article oh yes I know the drama
about her so the drama is that her
husband is Rich yeah her husband's dad
like started jeppo or something like
they're really wealthy and so that's
like her Scandal
right um that's like not a scandal like
it's not bad like it's not illegal to be
rich no so I guess what we're just
jealous like oh for sure but this is the
H and she has a $20,000 stove and no one
will ever let her forget it I think
people's issue by way that's like
literally not a lot of money relative to
how much money she has right people's
issue is that she's like promoting this
very difficult lifestyle while like
she's not promoting it she's literally
just living it and people happen to care
Claudia I stand with ballerina Farm no
no I know you're just like telling me
what what the discourse is but people
are dumb and stupid and why do she have
to live a certain way just cuz she has
money like No And it's like and it's
also not her like you don't know how
they live Jack the way this article was
like you know even though like like it
it's like how you would like I'm sorry
like I'm having a stroke I can't talk it
was so stupid like the fact that that's
attached to her as like her big Scandal
and like it somehow like invalidates
everything she does invalidates think
she does which is crazy gave birth eight
times everybody's like Eat the Rich like
the rich are so wasteful like this girl
is literally living the opposite of that
life like I'm sure she doesn't fly
private you know like they're literally
doing the opposite of what people hate
rich people for you know like excessive
wealth an abundance of things that that
that they don't need very wasteful
multiple homes carbon footprint like
she's doing the opposite and she's the
devil like I can't she's raing she
making her own jealous so jealous oh yes
they're so jealous yeah I am no but she
also like does it all cuz then she also
got a spray tan I'm like yes Queen
relatable oh wait she got a spray tan
she got a spray tan for Mrs America oh
of course of course but like literally
what's with you in Mrs America is it a
pageant of married women it's Miss
America no no no she's Mrs America not
Miss America Mrs America Miss America
was this weekend no she's a it's a
pageant of married women wait what are
you Ser Miss
America yeah there's Miss America and Ms
and she has been Mrs America now she's
going to you know support cuz it was
like Mrs Universe or something Mrs
world oh my God I didn't know that they
made a pageant like for misss yeah and
there's honestly like Jackie Jackie
should we enroll we should if I had to
scour you could be Mrs Florida and I
could be Mrs New York that would be a
dream if I had to scour the entire
country for a woman who is Mrs America
and embodies what you would Aspire a Mrs
America to be it'ser
no and I'm so glad that that that she
like found her way to that path I'm so
impressed by this woman it's not real
she's insane I saw her making this like
lemon curd well I was looking through
like her reals and one of them had 30
million views I'm like oh which one is
this and it was literally just a recipe
of her making like a lemon cake and it
like wasn't even like that high quality
like people just die for her it's crazy
yeah no and everything she does just
like it looks it's aesthetic but like
it's really not because it's just like
her and her house she lives in Utah
oh yeah and then also so there's like
this now that I engage with ballerina
farm so often she's one of my most
interacted with there is like this trend
on social media of Trad
wies what does that stand for I think
traditional wives oh I'm sorry I saw
this TRD TRD it's that's like the thing
and I see other TRD wives and a lot of
it some of it's like put on because like
they I think they like go and buy these
like huge dresses that like yeah right
and they put aprons costume it's cosplay
yeah but um but it's nice and they cook
and they put it all in the Bell Mason
jar yeah oh my they love a mason jar and
they're always like you know boiling
peaches yeah and the sleeves are
puffy yeah and it's
nice and I think it's like in the way of
fashion influencer like people distill
from that something they can take away
into their everyday life whether it's
just a new trend like oh I'm going to
wear a belt what if I wee this hat to
the party tonight like people follow
Trad wives and it's like hey maybe I
will cook
dinner maybe that's like me Trad wife
that's literally
you I'm a Trad wife like kind of but
because you like cook a lot and like
you're like a mom and stuff but you also
work which is kind of opposite I'm a
homem making Trad wife but it's just
like there's not definition of a of a
modern woman like your Trad wife who has
like a business yeah but these Trad
wives on Instagram like it's their
business too you know it's not just like
their home all day they're also making
content so they're not Trad wives I'm
sorry tread wives don't work it's
inherently contradictory it is but maybe
that's like the new kind of like a new
age for women like having it all you
know being a Trad wife who makes a
living yeah because also then you don't
have to sell your wees at the market if
you're making I'm sorry what like I feel
like traditionally a Trad wife if they
weren't filming themselves they would
make their Jarred goods and they would
go and sell their wees at the market no
I that that's no a tradwife like Waits
at home and cooks and cleans and waits
for the husband to come home like very
mad oh no I'm also I'm talking about
like a homesteading tradwife like doing
it all the most this conversation is not
English a homesteading tradwife yeah
like ballerina Farm's a homesteading
tradwife she doesn't just like sit at
home and make Betty Crocker title
homesteading tradwife greater
than
except you don't let us use greater than
symbols in our title because you can't
put in YouTube I just like also I'm over
the greater then oh I'm over this yeah
me too yeah who does
that not me anymore not a homesteading
Trad
wife but anyway a Trad wife like could
be like you know someone who makes bdy
crock or hamburger helper like ballerina
farm would literally never never I'm
glad that you came around to to her ways
she's so impressive also tell me who she
looks like and why is it Kelsey Owens
from that's good that's good they're
twins so Mao on the birth of her baby
beautiful ballerina I wonder if she
likes
podcasts like I don't know why I like
feel like she doesn't have electricity
like I know she does but like she does
like she has the Duna stroller like no
and she literally has like a tripod
because she makes content right and like
like I said she got a spray tan she got
a spray tan right and she took a plane
to Las
Vegas private or commercial unclear but
the photos air like it looked like a
regular airport well I would assume she
would fly jet blue right no but it was
giving like all those articles like
former you know where like he started it
but maybe he got like McDonald's out of
it right right right right right anyways
let's move on to the next story I'll
pick up we'll come back to her tomorrow
we'll Circle back this next story is one
of my favorite stories so my favorite
kind of story auo de has been slammed as
disrespectful for captioning her thirst
traps with an MLK quote
yesterday oh that is disrespectful So
Yesterday audre o day posted a tside
carousel in promotion of her only fans
very seductive sultry photos and the
caption is quote our lives begin to end
I was going to guess I was going to
guess only love could only light can
drive out Darkness like no that like
would have been better it was our lives
begin to end the day we become silent
about things that matter Martin Luther
King Jr that's the whole caption and I
do Wonder like how she thought that
related to like obviously it's beyond
inappropriate and out of touch but
that's not really my concern like I can
understand why she wouldn't understand
that but I'm just curious how it relates
to the pictures like you always your
caption is reflective of what the photos
consist of yes but I do feel like people
have become accustomed to just like
putting a quote on a photo and if you go
down that RAB too far without picking
your head up it's like okay here are my
photos of the day and what's a good
quote of this day MLK Day MLK quote no
I'm sorry this is really crazy like oh
no no no it's insane but I'm just saying
like I could see how someone could get
so caught up in like Instagram quote
culture that they miss that this is not
the move right like this is somebody
quoting like too close to the Sun yeah
cuz it's like okay I do a daily quote
maybe I should do like a daily quote for
the day that this is right right which
is MLK Day let me find a quote that
resonates with me now I think that this
is you know
reprehensible it's also extremely on
brand for aurio day like I actually
don't think this will affect her
standing in culture like whatsoever cuz
she's just kind of like known as like
this hot mess yeah and now everyone's
talking about it it was all in promotion
of her only fans like when you swipe
through the carousel there's a card that
like is like a meme about her only fans
fans so here we are like furthering
promoting her only fans it's kind of
brilliant she reminds me a lot of Lara
Pippen oh yeah just similar energies
similar bodies similar you know similar
energy yeah though Lara would never
Larsa would never know Larsa is like a
queen um also I saw something on Tik Tok
today that made me giggle so hard Justin
Timberlake's like out here on Tik Tok
like making hype videos that he's
releasing a new album and it's like the
way we don't care is so amazing to me
like in any other year if somebody was
of even like if
anybody if any no if anybody of similar
like size to Justin Timberlake like
started teasing a new album for the
first time in many many years like it
would be news this Tik Tok was like days
old yeah I had even heard about it you
know who I have to ask my husband I
that's my like litmus test like if my
husband cares about cuz he loved Justin
Timberlake back in the day so it's like
does he still have fans I will know if I
ask my husband the rise and fall of
Justin Timberlake should be studied by
scientists it's so crazy how literally
people were like he's Michael Jackson
like that video Vanguard Michael Jackson
like Michael Jackson Michael Jackson
King of Pop King of Pop like first of
all who the [__] wants to be the next
Michael Jackson he was literally a
pedophile nevertheless I progress I I
digress um the way he went from that to
like not being able to get [__]
arrested is truly it needs to be studied
it's it's a case study and what not to
do yeah but for so
long he was he was he was what to do
he's how you transition from a boy band
to a solo artist he was like the
blueprint I feel like I've been saying
like a lot today I really need to stop I
just keep I keep feeling myself saying
it I didn't notice I didn't notice we've
gotten so much better at that don't jinx
it we are far from perfect but I don't
know how the [__] people used to listen
to the show like five years ago I feel
as though the culture no people who
listened to us when we spoke like that
were in the same boat as us and I'm sure
they've improved too and then also it's
just more pleasant for everyone now that
we speak like this but we were younger
and I think younger people speak like
that and our audience was younger but
now we're all growing yeah yeah growing
we do it every day our fifth and final
story is little royal family news
because I absolutely need to talk about
my kings and queens so there's you know
always just rumors but I thought this
one was interesting Queen Elizabeth was
allegedly infuriated over Harry and
Megan's claim that she approved them
naming their daughter
lilbet no yeah so the late Queen
Elizabeth was infuriated that Megan and
Harry claimed that she gave their
blessing for their daughter to be named
liliet there's a new book that's why
there's all these rumors right now
there's a new book that's out um called
Charles III new king new court the
inside story because there was also
another book that came out like a few
weeks ago by omed scobby about like
Megan and Harry and there was like did
you see the drama about the
translation yeah that was crazy in one
of the like translated copies it said
who made the comment about Archie's skin
color and who was it I forget a lot of
the places wouldn't publish it because
it's liable right I feel like it was
Camila no I don't remember who it was
isn't that
crazy cuz there was a time Charles yeah
there was a time where like that piece
of information was what I needed to know
like I I could find out anything in this
world like I would want to know who said
it yeah so there's this new book and uh
one of the allegations in it is that the
queen was very mad that they said that
they got her approval apparently um one
man of the staff privately recall that
the queen had been as angry as I ever
saw her when they announced that in the
excerpt it said um that they called the
queen to let her know like we had the
baby and we're naming it after you but
like in a situation like that you don't
ask can we name it and you don't say no
you can't you know what I mean so then
it came out that it was lilette and then
they had said that they asked the queen
if they could use the name in this
person saying they never
asked okay it sounds like a little bit
like semantics and also
um oh this is tough cuz now I'm like
seeing things through the lens of the
crown I'm seeing everything through the
lens of this last season of the crown
and and just based on the part where I'm
at I feel
like I could actually see a world in
which like Harry hates his grandma yeah
I don't know why I had the idea that
Harry was the Queen's favorite like cuz
he was always like this like jokester
and they had a funny relationship and I
know the crown is not entirely truthful
but I don't think that's the case like I
think her I mean what we see in the
crown is represents everything that like
killed Diana yeah no on both ends like I
mean but I think Harry respects his
grandma but I don't think they had I
think if anyone had a special
relationship it's Elizabeth and William
not only because they are in the same
position but they have are of of a very
similar nature you know they both take
very seriously what they're doing and
throughout the seasons of the crown they
have like special like occasions or
instances or conversations that but I
know that's also just the show but they
don't just pull [__] out of thin air but
the way that the show the last few
episodes ended like it really left you
could see how the Riff begins like
especially between William and Harry the
way that it ends the last episode is
camil and Charles's wedding that's where
they decided to end the show I actually
thought it was a really nice place to
end it by the way I also didn't really
realize how long it took for them to get
married yeah I just kind of assumed that
him and Diana broke up and then like
shortly after he got married to cila but
I guess it was like a really really big
deal that he got remarried no and I
don't know how the firm feels about this
show but it is so good for them Charles
it first of all Dominic West has made me
like Charles so much as a future king as
a father I think he's like good on all
of those counts I it makes me like him
and Camila so much I I feel like you
know they probably feel like oh no the
crown it's like this bad thing but I
think it's done so much good for their
public perception at least for I know
how I feel about them and even as I was
watching the entire show I'm like I love
the queen love the queen but I've always
like disliked Charles cuz like he's
Charles but now that I'm done with it I
have like more respect for Charles and
William and Kate those are the best
episodes no but also I think so many
people dislike Charles because of Diana
but and I don't know if this was the
case in real life but in the show like
at the time of her death like they
actually were in a really good spot in
terms of like their relationship with
one another and co-parenting and things
like that so it's also tough because I
wasn't like alive or like conscious when
it was happening in real time so like
really everything I know about this is
from things like the crown yeah back to
lilet I actually don't believe
this uh I don't know I mean I'm sure
there's
some some things they feel one way they
feel another way but it is when you
think back on like after watching this
season and they're really like sewing
the seeds for Harry to be the rebel and
leave it's it's all just even weirder
like now that it's all brought to the
four again just because I'm in this time
period of like before he left and how it
all went down like it's so crazy cuz
even on the crown like the smallest
things are the biggest deal because it's
headline news and like when they
meited nothing on the crown has ever
been crazier probably since the um
abdication no or like Diana's
death yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah megit was crazy so that's
just like where I am right now and like
I'm I was here four years ago but it's
it's crazy all over again so now I'm
reading these headlines I'm
like yeah no it's hard like not to
believe whereas usually I'm like tabloid
trash they don't know anything right
right right right right right right
interesting but it was such a delight to
watch I'm so glad that I that I made the
time because it was fully immersive the
St Andrews episodes of William and Kate
like I was grinning from the fashion
show the I was grinning from ear to ear
don't
spoil from ear to ear it was just
lovely we'll talk about the season when
you're done with it okay I'm like now so
excited yeah you should like go treat
yourself today I will I have after this
I have an Amazon live make sure to tune
in and then I'm going to spend the night
watching the crown cuz Ben's out of town
and he doesn't watch it and it's like so
annoying so when he gets in bed I have
to turn it off unacceptable he could
learn a little something I'm sure he'd
love it I know but he really should
start from the beginning yeah I might I
mean I have so many things to rewatch
but that is on my rewatch list at some
point I mean I have so many things to
watch like all the housewives and
everything but like I want to rewatch
The Crown but I think it's going to make
me sad because she's no longer with us
like when I watch those seasons and I'm
so glad I watched them when they were
when she was alive cuz I had so much
appreciation for her at the end of her
life but now it's like it's just going
to be such a reminder like it's such the
end of era it's depressing yeah it's
like really
over well those were the past five you
definitely needed to know every single
one of them I'm so glad to be back we've
got a great week of shows don't let us
forget to do Queenie and weenie of the
week on Friday M hold us accountable yep
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toast show okay I have no voice like
I really I'm not I'm not gonna and I got
to go and the episodes got to go up love
you
bye